so hello everybody i am back here with
richard rowland
everybody has been really excited about
our last discussion on ethiopia
yeah i've been surprised to see how fast
it's been growing on the channel
it seems like it's such a it's kind of
an obscure subject but
it actually seems to be touching on a
lot of aspects of this re-enchantment
and mystery
you know and uh and a different way of
seeing peoples of the world which i i
find very exciting and so
i'm really looking forward to seeing
what richard has in store for us and i
have a few things
in my uh up my sleeve as well
uh i i just have to say i've got more i
mean i
i don't do nearly as much stuff on the
internet as you do but i've gotten
more uh positive feedback on that
ethiopia video than i've ever gotten
on i think anything i've ever done um
i've gotten emails from people who are
like oh
let me put you in touch with this person
you guys should have a conversation but
i've also gotten like you know just like
a bunch of shout outs from like random
rasta guys
and uh and uh yeah so it's been
it's been uh you know a lot of a lot of
love from some of my
my my ethiopian and eritrean friends uh
over the video so i'm really
really pleased about that like i said i
i uh i told you this a minute ago but
like i i was pretty sure this is the
video that was going to get me canceled
so i've been
been really encouraged to see so much
support for it so
yeah but i think i think it was
transparent for a lot of people to see
just the enthusiasm we have about
ethiopian culture and
you know also this kind of surprise that
we have that nobody knows about it
and this desire to help people see the
the kind of pearl that's hidden there
in northern africa for most of us you
know we don't we don't right
a lot of people don't know about it but
it definitely is a pearl
well so this this actually i mean this
will be a good
segue into kind of everything we're
talking about today okay because i
i've watched a couple of response videos
you probably have as well to the
universal history series that people
have made on youtube
and one of the really interesting
criticisms
about about it was
uh let's say twofold first of all that
oh well this idea of like a medieval
european
universal history it doesn't have room
for the chinese
it doesn't have room for africans it
doesn't have room for
you know this whatever group that you
want to pick that that you sort of like
see as being sort of outside the
traditional european christian story
um so one of the things that that
hopefully this ethiopia
video helps helps people sort of get
is that the the story of christ and
and really here you know i'm talking
specifically traditional christianity
really is all-encompassing it does have
room
to integrate all of these things but
it's also it's a it's a story that
hasn't ended right and so this is the
other i
somebody somebody made the remark you
know um i think this is when we were
talking in the
our second video that we did together um
about christ and antichrist you know
talking about liturgy and you know this
idea
that the liturgy is sort of like
interrupted and constantinople and that
one days can be finished and things like
this and
somebody said uh well you know if if if
liturgy was going to save us
it would have already worked like it
would have already saved us and i was
just
i i kind of squinted a little bit at my
computer screen and i was like
you know that's like saying well if
jesus was going to save us he already
would have like why are there
bad things in the world no why do bad
things happen like this is
it's kind of a silly it's kind of a
silly argument um
but but here's the here's the thing that
i i want to i'm going to kind of
point to and sort of show today is that
the story's not over
right um and this is i think this would
be true for both of us
is that we really uh we still see
ourselves as part of this story it's a
story that's
that's ongoing um and that in some way
um you know they're one one of the the
key parts
of post-modernism which i think was
actually really useful
uh was this ability to conceive of
oneself as being part of a narrative
yeah um there's the even that even
tolkien is engaging with us when he says
in um you know the lord of the rings
there's that moment at the
at the the stare of kirit ongold when
when sam is looking up at the sky and he
sees the star arendo which is connected
to the light and the silmarils and the
the
the file of light that uh that frodo's
carrying with him right now
and he starts to realize hey all these
things are actually connected
there's a larger pattern here that we're
actually manifesting and he says
you know we're in the same story after
all right
and so i think maybe one of the more
helpful things that postmoderate is
post-modernism has done is it's given us
a way to
kind of recapture the ability to
conceive of ourselves as being
part of this larger narrative which
which is
exactly what universal history is this
is the way that in the middle ages
they saw themselves as being part of
this larger narrative and it's important
it's really important to point out to
people that when we say universal
history
we don't mean it at all in a kind of uh
enlightenment scientific
vision of kind of pulling yourselves out
of the world and now looking at all of
history as
one big thing no it's a it's universe
it's it's a universal history
but it's a universal history that's
embodied and lived in the particular
histories and so it's normal that you
will also see
let's say fractally you'll see those
histories that are further away from you
as being further away from you and so
there's a letter
there's less room in the universal
history for the chinese
although there is and we will get to it
at some point
especially when we talk about uh mongols
and stuff and we get to that kind of
stuff
we'll talk about that um but there is
less room in the sense that it's just
further away
and so this is also it's important to
understand that that's how it works it
works as this idea of
these centers that have their
perspective
but these perspectives also fit together
in a
in a kind of puzzle but it's not a it's
not a it's not a god's eye view puzzle
but it's an embodied puzzle that you
encounter from the piece that you are in
that puzzle let's say it that way right
every society when it encounters
christianity for the first time
is on the margin just sort of by default
right uh but then but then of course you
know as
as it expands right these things sort of
change and they shift a little bit and
it takes a
you know it's a this is not a it's not a
rigorously
uh you know i a lot of times when we're
especially let's say dudes of a certain
age
who are like you know trying to trying
to grapple with their world what they
really want is this
this hyper rigorous internal system
where everything has a one-to-one
mapping and things like that and it's
it's a little more of an art than that
yeah um and this this actually
kind of ties into uh this is not a
question i want to answer today
um though i think there is an answer but
the question that i've been asked the
most
since we started doing the series and
this is it's the most american question
to possibly ask
is well where does america fit into this
story you know that's what this is what
we're really concerned about is like
okay but
but where do i fit in and that's this is
nothing i mean
in a certain sense there's nothing wrong
with that but we are of course you know
we are a little self-involved a little
self-interested
here in in america um but uh and so this
is actually something i've been
pondering a lot in the oca
um uh we had the uh we this last sunday
was the sunday of all saints of north
america and it was just a really good
which actually is wonderful serendipity
landed on
july 4th which is independence day in
the united states um i don't know if
you've heard of this
but we we just blow stuff up for about
three days straight
um it's it's a good time but um
uh so so i've had a but it just gave me
a lot of occasion to kind of ponder you
know where does america fit into this
symbolic story um
and so i think that if people pay
attention to this video these next few
videos
they're gonna start uh they'll
they're they're gonna be clues and by
the time we actually get to talking
about america i think that uh
um it'll help make sense um i i really
want to
once we kind of finish going down this
particular uh trail that we're on i kind
of want to like
uh shift gears a little bit and look at
uh look at
celtic christianity look at ireland and
wales uh which are also
you know out there on the edge of the
world we touched on that a little bit
with the arthur stuff but i think
there's
there's a lot more there that's gonna
help us understand the symbolism of the
edge actually in another way
and um so anyway it's just a teaser i'm
really bad about these teasers but
yes there's a lot to talk about
there's someone to talk about what what
i thought we'd do for this video
is now that we've we've constantly
teased it
like we keep we keep referring back to
this apocalypse of pseudomethodius
which is in this wonderful volume by
dumbarton oaks
uh because it's and it's not the only
work like this there's actually a really
rich
byzantine apocalyptic tradition that
kind of is is in and around this builds
off of it predates it etc
um but i like the apocalypse of
pseudomythoides for a few reasons one is
this just
there's a really handy easily accessible
english translation of the work
uh it's easy to find people can pull it
up
uh and and read it and it's not on like
a sketchy website
um like you know some of this old stuff
is you know like i don't i don't know
how like legit this is like you know i
need a little more textual certainty or
something like that you know
but um basically all of the things that
we're talking about
we see we find in the apocalypse of
pseudo methodius
in a byzantine kind of a focus so it's
not a particular
let's say western focus in the sense
that although really the notion that
greek
civilization is not western is i just
constantly find that ludicrous but
but it's but it's not a particularly
let's say a latin or western or uh you
know like a protestant
colonialist you know et cetera et cetera
all these things that are
that are so easily problematized right
this list is kind of like cut through
some of that noise and look at how does
this pattern
work how does this this idea of
universal history work out
uh the other thing though is that the
apocalypse of pseudomothodius is aimed
specifically at answering one of the
main criticisms
uh which which we've received and i've
heard this from two or three different
people
which is well okay but constantinople
fell
so there your argument's invalid like
obviously if if if christianity was
legit if orthodoxy is legit if universal
history is legit then like why did
why did constantinople fall right
and so so one of the things that uh the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius is
actually set to grapple with
is the is the rise of islam and the arab
conquest
and that's actually i mean it's not a
it's not an illegitimate question
uh if you're pretty sure you're on god's
side
and then that doesn't end up looking
like you know military might
then you know it's a it's a pretty
normal thing to ask as many people have
over history it's a pretty normal thing
to ask well why are we losing
yeah and is is this thing that i'm a
part of
and i really actually like uh dr mario
uh uh
in his his video that that he did with
you earlier in the series you know he
talks about the fact that one of the
things that byzantium is doing that
constantinople is doing
is it's really it's really giving
its life to the church right it really
gives up
you know this high level of cultural
development all of these things and puts
them into the deep treasury of the
orthodox church
so that even when constantinople falls
the orthodox church has continued
oftentimes under like truly crushing
opposition um and that's not just here
to you know like
chill for orthodoxy obviously i'm
orthodox i love it
i would like everyone to be you know but
the point of this is that one of the
questions that has to be answered is
this idea
well can my faith outlast my government
right that the you know like if what is
it what would it mean to have a
christian country that then falls
to conquest from a non-christian group
right um and that's actually one of the
questions that the studio
the the the apocalypse of
pseudomethodius um that is it's
attributed to this early church father
he's like a third or fourth century
church father named methodius
um scholars because they hate fun um
will say that this is probably written
more like the sixth or the seventh
centuries um actually maybe around the
same time as the
iconoclast controversy in the in the
east so
okay all that to say
from the very beginning the apocalypse
sets
up this tension between
uh between the center and the edge
but also it's it's a work that is deeply
concerned
with giants and in fact
i didn't look like you paused when you
said giants i didn't i didn't wanna i
didn't tell you that i was gonna talk
about this
uh but one of the things that i'm really
con uh interested in
is the idea so this is what it says
about the birth of seth
it says in the 230th year of the first
millennium that is also the first age
seth was born a gigantic man
in the likeness of adam
in the 500th year in the same first
millennium the sons of cain abused the
wives of their own brothers in excessive
fornications
so this is uh this is a
it's an interesting work because uh
basically this work
takes both the approach that there are
fallen angels involved
uh but also that that is sort of like
line of cane line of seth like it's uh
it's a is kind of a hybrid of those two
different hypotheses
uh but one of the really interesting
things here is that uh
seth is is uh seth is
put out as a giant and
as we keep reading
we uh
we find that there are there are
actually kind of like two groups of
giants
um two groups of you know and i think we
can understand this as being like these
are large these are powerful like a
giant is a very
um the way dante uses giants in the
divine comedy is to basically be like
they're too
fleshy they're too they've got too much
body right
so uh they're they're large they're
powerful they
they're in other words like they're this
massive amount of potential
and um and what ends up happening is
that
seth and his children go up and
living and raising the line of seth
raising their family on thus
the slopes of the mountain of paradise
right and that kane and his
people are are down in the valley um and
that this is this this is in the
the pseudo-methodius yeah yeah this is
all this is all in the apocalypse yeah
yeah um it's basically it's like a
snapshot of
this kind of cosmology i think yeah kind
of said ephraim's
the the the cosmology we find in
cenephram's paradise
yes um and so what what happens then
what what ends up happening is uh is
that the these
devils these fallen angels they come to
the line of cain and they specifically
uh pollute and corrupt the line of
canaan by teaching them the composition
of every kind of music is what it says
your brother matthew in his book has
some really great things to say about
music and his relationship to
ornamentation to variability
even to things like menstruation
um and uh so so you can sort of see
you've got the mountain of paradise
right here you've got
seth and his people living on the slopes
of the mountain they're not quite in
paradise but they're kind of as close as
they can get
and then out here on the margin that's
where the light of cain
uh is and there's there's basically
ideas that what's happening in the the
people of cain is that there's all kinds
of mixture
so there's every kind of music and this
is i mean this is a real problem the
ancient world is figuring out
how to uh i mean this is one of the
plato's main things that he's concerned
with
in in many of his writings is the idea
that there's
there are there's certain music that
would be appropriate for a certain time
and for a certain place
um and that there are actually some
kinds of music let's say some tones
some modes that plato actually believed
it would be wrong to even let common
people hear
like you shouldn't even play those in
public um and of course this is one of
the things that in the orthodox church
uh especially in the byzantine tradition
it gets resolved and i mean this
happened in the west to
uh up to a certain point uh but this
gets to revolve
result in the tonal system right the
eight tone uh system
in the in the east but also like in
gregorian chant things like this in the
west
where it was basically saying okay there
really does there really is like a
hierarchy of music
and as strange as this might sound to
lots of people living in america
there really is music that's okay to
listen to it your house that you
shouldn't play in church
of course right yeah and you can
understand it very simply as a hierarchy
of patterns and that right
and that different there are different
types of patterns and those patterns
have a place in the world
um and and that like you said like they
just have their place and some of them
maybe don't have
their place like in in public life let's
say because they can bring about
no i mean you can understand it's like
the music that plays in a club
like a is music that plays in a club and
there's a reason why the things that
happen in a club happen in a club and
the type of
relationships and the type of kind of
decadence that you see
which is related to consumption to to
fornication to all that there is
that the music itself is
is it's not just the music but the music
is part of the pattern
that is bringing about these kinds of
things and and so if you listen to like
a folk dance
you can't do the same things that you
would do in a club while you're
listening to a folk dance there's a
it just it just doesn't allow it in its
pattern
right right yeah so it's really what's
really interesting is that it's called
the
camp of cane right so at this point at
this point a city
in this particular narrative there isn't
really a sense of like
a an uh a city so much as it is
the camp and the idea is actually sort
of the idea of a club floor
you know it's like there's there's all
kinds of music there's
there's a vast amount of mixture
happening out here around the
in the valley you know at the sort of
the foot of paradise at the mountain of
paradise
so we're told if you've seen the movie
the second matrix movie
that whole rave scene at the in the cave
that's what's happening there you go
yeah or the rave sort of slash
uh well well the last last
video i talked about the ten
commandments yeah
the wave at the bottom of the mountain
right at the bottom of the mountain is
actually
is actually really really well done and
if you
just as a little side note because i
love this movie uh
a lot if you if you kind of look into
like some of the making of the movie it
took them
uh two or three weeks i believe to shoot
that scene
and it was just incredibly grueling up
on the people who
who had to shoot it but anyway because
there's so many people in such mayhem so
many people
and yeah just like very physically
exhausting to shoot
so we're told that they're around the
base of the mountain of paradise that
the
in the campbell cane they're more of
even more inflamed in their abominable
fortification
they become worse than the previous
generation
they mount each other in the metal
manner of animals and you know there's
some explicit stuff in here but it's
you know it's it's uh you know all kinds
of debauchery all kinds of fornication
anything you can imagine
right that's that's all happening here
and
um and this is this is
uh so then it says in the 700th year of
the life of jared
that is in the second millennium the
spiteful and troublesome devil
applied to himself to bring applied
himself to bring the war of fornication
to the sons of seth
so that they should desire the daughters
of cain and he pushed them on
uh there appeared giants in the earth
the sons of seth who fell into the pit
of sin and became altogether
dreadful so there's actually there's
like this devil
so you have fallen angels plus kane plus
seth so it's like again it's like a
hybrid
it's like a kind of a hybrid approach to
that whole question so they actually
have the idea that
fallen angels had relationships with
women but then also the tradition of
seth having a relationship right with
with
with kane yes yes and i always always
thought that those two were just the
same at different levels of reality i've
always said that
yeah i well and that's the thing like a
lot of people are like oh well
this church father says it was this way
so you know like lord of spirits podcast
is wrong or something like this but
you have to realize that most people in
the in the middle ages especially in the
east
did not see these things as mutually
exclusive yeah and a way to actually
understand this is like once you start
you know the
things that they talked about you know
especially in their the land of giants
episode on the lord a lord of spirits
about the nephilim ritual and things
like this you can understand how you
could have
two humans from from differing
uh who who in this story are actually at
different like ontological levels right
because you have the
you know the light of seth is kind of up
here and then kane is down here so you
can actually have two humans coupling
but also there's a demon involved in
that somehow right yes and then two
levels
at a different level like let's say a
priest and a prostitute let's say
pretty simple like it's it it can just
happen it can it happens
fractally at the material level but it's
representing a higher
a higher reality which is also happening
simultaneously
right so all of this happens of course
then you have the you have
uh i promise we're getting to ethiopia
so all of this happens this is actually
all set up for the ethiopia thing
um there's like i think seven or eight
chapters that are basically it's like
it's just
an expanded narrative of the genesis
history right
um and it explains explains we have the
we have the uh you know
all the things that we've talked about a
lot and that you've talked about a lot
on this channel
you know the the the center and the
margin that you know that the
the mixture resulting in the creation of
something monstrous all these different
things
uh those patterns just recapitulate
themselves over and over
again and what it eventually results in
is in the line of ham
um uh which is which is you know this is
going to be relevant to
relevant to when we're talking about
ethiopia
um we're told we're told that uh
uh well first of all we're told that
noah has
an extra son uh and the the the idea of
the extra son of noah
this guy's name is junitos
this is a this is a pretty popular uh
medieval tradition that there was like
this one extra sun
and he actually goes to the land of the
rising sun
is what we're told the country of the
sun where the rising of the sun takes
place
and he lives there and it says that
unitas received from god the gift of
wisdom not only this alone but he also
became the inventor of every division of
astronomy
and so that nimrod actually came down
and learned from him
and received from him the council by
which he might begin his rule
so so you have nimrod all these things
but so you have this you have this
fourth son of noah
who goes to the very eastern edge of the
world now remember that ethiopians
uh in the greek conception
sort of come from one of two places they
either come from the extreme west
which is weird to think of ethiopia
being in the extreme west but if you
live in ancient greece
it's less weird right yeah um because
africa is in the west
um so you have you have ethiopians in
the extreme west where the sun comes
down and then you also have them in the
extreme east where the sun comes up
so this is actually setting up this
whole way of sort of thinking about
uh thinking about um and of course
people
in in you know byzantium at this time or
this might have actually been written in
syria
uh but people people in in this that
part of the world this time they
they definitely knew there were these
huge uh
civilizations to the east right uh which
had achieved a very
high level of learning you know
sometimes people
point this out i was listening to
something last night where somebody
is pointing out that um oh well
you know medieval christians didn't know
that you know china and
and india and all these you know they
had these high levels of civilization
and they just thought they were the best
thing on earth and all the stuff and
it's
it's not it's not true it's not uh they
had a mythical way of representing right
but they right
the legend of the naked philosophers was
there all through all through the
time yeah so this is this is the
basically the explanation for that where
did those guys come from they actually
they they are descended from like a
fourth son of noah
who goes to the land of the rising sun
and is actually taught by
god all of this lore all of this wisdom
which is then sort of there preserved
there on the edge of the world after the
flood
okay so this is all this is all kind of
related to how ethiopia
comes into the story um
um and there's there's a war between um
i don't want to get into too much of
this but people people go read this
because there's a really interesting
thing that happens there's a war between
the descendants of japheth would be like
what we would call europeans today and
between the descendants of shem
this fourth son of noah actually tries
to intervene
in this and the reason he says that you
need to enter he tries to intervene in
this is to say
that there are some descendants of ham
this is going to be
arabia uh who's actually going to rise
up and
and take you both out if you don't sort
of like band together right so here so
here's the idea it's like you have these
european people
and you have these semitic people and
they're set up
a very real tension that existed even in
the ancient world between those people
groups
but then also there's this intuition
that
there's something vital about the the
preservation of christianity has to come
from a union between those two people
um and that this union the the source of
this union is gonna come
from outside and so
the narrative continues on and it gets
us all the way
to the time of alexander
and what we're told is that philip the
father of alexander said this is now in
chapter eight of the apocalypse
that philip the father of alexander he's
a macedonian king and that he
marries now i know that in a lot of
myths and legends especially medieval
missing legends he marries an egyptian
princess
right but in the apocalypse she's
ethiopian
her name is chuseth and she's the
daughter of king full of ethiopia
and all of their like all of their
lineage has been very carefully laid out
from beforehand
so you see how she's from you know the
ethiopians are descended from
from uh kush who's from the light of ham
and all the stuff
and and so so you have
uh so you have philip he marries joseph
this ethiopian
queen and from her is born alexander
and we get the story of alexander and
all of his
all of his his conquest and everything
else
and this culminates in his encountering
the descendants
of uh so he goes he goes east
to the country towards the country of
the sun right and there was going east
towards india
and that's when he encounters these in
these descendants of the son of japheth
who are you know europeans uh but who
have
who have gone the way of cain right and
so they've they're they're out sort of
here on the edge of things
and and they've participated in the this
mixture
they've become cannibals uh they all eat
in the semblance of the beetle
it says and so they're like bugs bugs in
the earth yeah i mean this is like
um so in other words you know like a
beetle just like rummages around in
in filth and dying things to decay
things and things that are
that are broken down and and mixed
beyond
uh the level of coherence
and uh so it says they eat every
polluted and filthy things
dogs mice snakes carrion abortions
miscarriages yeah there you go those
which in the womb
you know like i mean this is a i'm not
even going to read that whole bit
because it gets really intense but
basically
basically it's like it's it's awful
right so they're
they're and they shouldn't laugh but
it's like yeah
here's like the the kind of gog and
magog imagery here right so so that so
they're called
they're not initially called gog and
magog but that phrase is used
later on and so this and so what he does
is of course he drives them north
um uh because because what he's trying
to do is prevent them from getting to
the holy land
right so he drives them north you know
to this place in the caucuses
uh and there's still it's i mean it's a
real place right alexander's it's still
called alexander's gates it's also
called the pabst of the north
uh which is a great band name for
somebody out there if you wanna it's not
go it's not do that don't do that okay
sorry never mind
um and he builds these gates um
and he builds the gates out of this out
of this special metal
which uh which basically can't
be uh it's it's they're made out of
something that can't be touched by
demons
specifically so the idea is that these
these it says these filthy and misshapen
or vile nations employed in unclean
fashion all of the evils of magical arts
right and so the so he has to make gates
that are going to
that are going to sort of stand against
magic gates magic gates they're made
magic gates the magic gates
um and so what we're told then
uh getting into this getting into this
uh
this prophecy um so in our last video i
read
some stuff from the prophecy of ezekiel
which talks about all these nations and
the idea that ethiopia and the land of
the the rivers beyond the rivers of
ethiopia beyond the rivers of cush
is being sort of like one extreme end of
the world right and
i think we should say at this point that
when we talk about the symbolism of the
edge
although somewhere like ireland and
somewhere like ethiopia are both kind of
on the edge
and so they share certain similarities
they're also different
um because the direction that you're
going in also has a lot of importance
in in this sort of symbol yeah which
edge of the world which edge which edge
are we talking about
right so this particular which is like
the northern edge
um it's different from it's different
from beyond the land of ethiopia right
these are the people's
um which you know which are later
identified with with groups like the
goths
group like you know these basically the
whole barbarian
invasion period of european history so
it says
in the end times of course but also the
huns too like right also the huns yeah
but so the huns are the huns are really
interesting in this
because
they're they're precisely one of these
groups that is like
sort of like maybe they're asian but
maybe they're like european
yeah that's not totally clear uh even
even even the mongolians like they're
they're weird legends of uh
of genghis khan with green eyes and
stuff so even the mongols
like that it's not clear they weren't
it's not clear that the image of mongols
we have now
is what people encountered at that time
so so attila the hun's name
right isn't it's not a it's not an asian
name
his name is is it's atlee which is
gothic it's a which is a european
language
it's a scandinavian language his name is
uh
or germanic anyway his his name is is
octley
and oct basically means something like
little daddy
so it's like an affectionate name that
his soldiers have probably wasn't his
real name
yeah you know he probably has some other
name but occlude is what everyone called
him
you know um this is
i mean this is a really interesting
they're actually a couple of real
members who have like a really similar
nickname because they used to follow the
troops around like as you know like as a
boy they went with their dad on
campaigns and like
you know stumped around the camp in
their dad's boots or whatever and
and so the impression seems to be
something similar happened with attila
so even even the huns are not they're
not uh
they're exactly this they're exactly
this kind of a group that there's
there's there's an idea that some kind
of mixture has taken place here we're
not really sure what it is
right but that's that's exactly what
this legend is trying to deal with
so it says in the end times according to
what the prophecy of ezekiel says
in the last day of the consummation of
the world will come into the land of
israel
gog and magog and that these are the
nations and the kings
that alexander hid in the ends of the
north
so gog and magog and it just goes on it
lists all these nations among these
nations by the way
it mentions the aggro martians and the
onophagians
anaphagians probably mean something like
buttlicker
in in latin um
uh if you can think about the way that
dogs greet each other
yeah yeah yeah yeah and the reason is
because the anaphasians are also called
the
cyanocephalians in other words they're
dog-headed men right so yeah
yeah so it's all in there and a lot can
help you understand what the dog in and
men also
another way of understanding what it
meant right right so when you come into
like the legends of saying christopher
and things like this that's that's
what's going on right yeah
and so it says these are the 22 kings
that are shut up within the gates that
alexander fixed
so uh so there's this is like one
chapter in the apocalypse
and the point of this chapter is
basically just to
uh refer to this story that everyone
knows right because this is a universal
history
so it's to refer to the story everyone
else everyone knows alexander did this
right this is just part of what everyone
sort of believed in the at this
particular time in history
um and so it's also it's a way of
explaining uh
it's a way of explaining actually a
future disaster a future apocalypse like
this
this hasn't you know from the
perspective of when this is being
written this hasn't happened yet
right so um
with that kind of out of the way and
it's not it's not
unimportant for the rest of the story
but like with that kind of said it
returns to this question of alexander's
lineage
so alexander is half macedonian but he's
he's uh he's half in this story he's
half ethiopian
right um so you can think that's
actually a really interesting image of
something that comes from the edge and
actually comes as a result of mixture
from the edge
is then the source of purity right
that's what
drives these monstrous things kind of
away in the opposite direction too right
not south but north
it's what drives the launchers things
away so at this point it returns to
uh it returns to the story of alexander
and basically what happened
is after alexander's death his empire is
split among his four servants as pretty
much i think everyone knows
and when this happens his mother joseph
returns to ethiopia okay
all right so now now we're getting into
the stuff that i kind of teased in the
last video
bezos who's the founder of byzantium
he sends to uh sends the chief of his
army
over the sea to the king of ethiopia
he wants to make a marriage alliance
with ethiopia
and he writes to him concerning joseph
the mother of alexander
because he wants to take her as wife
himself and make her his queen okay so
bisas
founder of byzantium right and it's a
he's a he's a let's say uh
from a modern perspective he's a
semi-historical person right byzantium
was named
byzantium because it was named after
somebody who founded it right yeah
obviously later on
constantine will come level the place
and rebuild it
right uh but it was already it wasn't a
large place at that time but it was
already it was
it was in kind of an important place
it's it's founded by like
uh like most things that's founded by
like a refugee from troy and all this
different stuff so
sends off up to ethiopia and he asks
for the ethiopian princess who's the
mother of alexander
to wife um and so this all goes well um
the the king of ethiopia sends his
daughter back and she marries
visas um and
uh the place where the marriage is
affected
is at the city of chalcedon yeah
yeah so this is where uh
this is where we have to sort of like
turn to ecclesiastical history for a
moment
right obviously we alluded to this in
the last video
there is currently um you know you and i
are in the eastern orthodox church
there's currently a schism that's been
going on for like 1500 years now
between the uh the calcidonian orthodox
church
and the the group that is sometimes
called oriental orthodox
and that's actually kind of a kind of a
newer name that's been given to them
mainly by like anglican scholars and it
really cracks me up because orient is
the same word as east
so like yeah you know but um
but let's see just just you know to
avoid the whole monopoly me if it's
right
probably right yeah it's like do we yes
it's self-named or is it the name that
we use to talk about them you know
yeah and here i have to say you know
with all love to my my ethiopian my
eritrean friends
um i you know i i'm not one of these
people who believes like it was all just
a linguistic misunderstanding
um and the reason i don't believe that
is because my main policy for operating
in life
is to not assume that that our ancestors
were idiots
right like to say oh it was just a big
linguistic misunderstanding but
now you know effect you know 1500 years
removed from when these languages were
spoken as living languages
we can see through it and they couldn't
i'm
i'm uh i'm skeptical let's say i'm a
little dubious about that
um so so there is this chasm between us
it's a realism
um uh and that doesn't mean there's not
a lot of love
going both ways because there is you
know but there is there is a
there is a realism between us
and the person who is writing this you
know apocalypse is probably
uh writing it he's he's probably in
syria we think
um which is which is strongly affected
by that schism
right um so he's probably syrian
and he's living probably only let's say
maybe a hundred years after it happened
okay so this is a this is a very real
reality to him
the fact that this happened at calcidon
is a very strong
you know present reality to him so in
his story
the marriage alliance between byzantium
and ethiopia
right which are on two sides of this
question is affected at the same place
the schism happens
yeah it's affected at calcidon
king bezos bezos marries joseph and they
have a daughter
named byzantia and they marry byzantia
off to a guy who's referred to in the
text as
romulus the king of rome so
you have this this marriage alliance
between byzantium and ethiopia
and then that results in something that
joins byzantium ethiopia and
rome yeah right and of course rome
in the west played a huge role in that
particular schism right it's the
it's the it's the tome of leo right red
at the fourth council
that really cinched it it said pinched
it right
and causes this rift so
what the author is doing here is he's
very carefully
building this idea that
uh from this marriage alliance that
there's something
in this in the history of the ancient
world that goes all the way back to
alexander
right what is alexander's role
alexander's role is to push the
barbarians away
to seal the gate against you know the
you know the barbarians are literally at
the gate when we're talking about
alexander right
so his goal his his role is really to
play this role of
of uh unity and and purity
right but it's not a it's not a
monolithic purity
alexander is himself have ethiopian in
the story right
uh but it's a way of it's a way of um
this goes back to this this very strange
idea that i haven't actually encountered
anywhere else
earlier in the apocalypse that seth was
a giant
right so there's some kind of idea here
um maybe you could speak to this a
little bit because i've talked a lot
yeah well there's a there's a there's a
difference between there's a
how can i say this there is a moment or
there's a possibility
for something like uh hybridity to
become
synthetic to become an actual new being
so
so were you mentioning this was this in
one of your last videos or was this in
the q
a it's in a q a that i talked about that
so so this this was
really important so maybe you could say
a little bit about this again because i
think this is
this is probably the best part about
whole q a yeah well there is
there especially right now it's really
important to see that because they're
the one of the biggest problems we have
right now
is we are struggling to tell the
difference between
um confusion and unity
right that is the unity of multiplicity
into a new identity
and the the union of multiplicity which
is actually not a union which is just a
confusion of different identities that
can't sort themselves out
and it's hard for people it's hard
because it's a really existential
experience it's hard to it's hard to
define
the difference between um
you know something when you look at it
you know it like you look at something
and you say well that's like uh
that's like two things it's not one
thing you can't tell that it's one thing
it doesn't come together into one um
and so you can see that for example the
example i gave is
is exactly britain for example there's a
moment in which britain was just a bunch
of different
groups fighting amongst each other and
you could say
britain but it wasn't it was just this
mixture of people
and then something happened you know
something sacred
something high up on the scale of being
which was able to join them together so
that now
they recognize each other as having a
true unity
and it doesn't it doesn't deny their
multiplicity it doesn't annul it
but it makes a multiplicity participate
in a unity and so this is really the
difference
so right now we talk about things like
like the whole idea of intersectionality
right intersectionality is really is
this worship of
diversity for itself and it's like the
opposite of unity
it's like right like the one who can
accumulate the most idiosyncrasy
wins rather than seeing how those
idiosyncrasies
can be joined together with our
different idiosyncrasies
to to uh to actually express unity um
and so it's sometimes it can confuse us
because it almost looks like each other
but it's it is like it is like a mere
reflection one of the other
so this is this this is maybe just
exactly
let me give you let me give an example
like i've actually one example i've
given recently in
in the q a is the difference between
christ and bafflement
it's a very it's like it's a pretty
clear example because
in kind of this kind of occult tradition
uh they have this sense of the union of
heaven and earth they talk about
you know as above so below but the image
that they come up with in the 19th
century is a hybrid creature
is a hybrid hermaphroditic creature with
like the head of a goat and the breasts
of a
of a woman and still seeming to be a man
you know and so it's like they confuse
um
synthesis and and uh and hermaphroditis
hermaphroditism like the idea of having
two sexes at the same time
that's not the that's that's not unity
and so you could say it's like the
difference between
the someone that is an angel that is
beyond sex
and a confused being that is a mixture
of all these different
of these different identities and so
that's the difference so christ
is both man and god
complete not no mixture it's really
important for the definition of christ
that there's no mixture between the two
natures but completely united in one
person so that
so that they also can't be uh separated
let's say
and so that is the image of synthesis
whereas something like baphomet it
really is the image of confusion
yeah there has to be i mean so so you
just you just
mentioned the hypostatic union which is
you know like the technical term for
that idea that christ says
and this is actually what that that
schism is over that we were just talking
about between the calcidone and
non-calcitinian churches
is over this question right and so the
the church is teaching on this is that
christ has two natures divine and human
perfectly joined in his hypothesis his
person
right his his uh you know the the second
person of the trinity that these two
natures are joined but not
mingled not confused and um
i'll give a i'll give a weird example
because people keep asking about
symbolism of america
and i'm just gonna i'll just tease this
i'll just tease this okay
so uh you might have heard we had a
civil war a couple hundred years ago
here in the united states
it's kind of a thing um so
in our name right there's a plurality in
the name
the united states right what is a state
a state is not a province a state is a
you know like the traditional definition
of the state
is that a state is like it's it's like a
standalone self-governing
principality of some kind right so
um so we're the united states and so the
idea is that you had all of these
standalone principalities who would come
together to cooperate on certain
levels right and that was the let's say
that was one vision of what america
might be right uh and it's not
what came out of the civil war and and
the reason it didn't come out of the
civil war is because
there was no uh there was no higher
principality
right there was no sacred direction
toward which each of those
those individual things could orient
themselves right
and so what ended up what ends up
happening is of course you have some
band together against others that band
together and you have a war
so the the way that this i'm going to
just say on a symbolic
level the way that the unity of the
united states manifests in the post
civil war area
is actually in the person of abraham
lincoln
and the reason that i believe this is
the case
is because if we go to washington dc we
have a temple to abraham lincoln in
washington dc and it really is
it really is a temple like it says it's
a temple
on the temple right there's there's uh
there's an engraving behind this
so it's a it's modeled on a on an
ancient temple of zeus i forget which
one
but it's modeled on an ancient temple of
zeus and then sitting in the center in
the throne instead of zeus it's abraham
lincoln
and uh there's an inscription behind him
that's culture man it's got a lot of
that double that double nature to it
because they actually in the sculpture
itself
they have one side of abraham lincoln
which is kind of ordered
and the other side of abraham lincoln
which is kind of disoriented it's a
little like
like what's going on that pantone the
icon of the
yeah it's really interesting and so
behind his head in an inscription that
says
in this temple as in the hearts of those
for whom he saved the union
abraham lincoln will be forever
enshrined something like that
and like listen to the language there
the ideas that abraham lincoln has come
into your heart
and he has saved you i mean that's
deliberately
like that's in the language of the
lincoln memorial yeah
but at the roo the roof of the lincoln
memorial and i think it's very
interesting that it's the roof and not
say the floor
but at the roof of the lincoln memorial
you have
the engraved names of all all the states
that were in the union at the time the
memorial was built
right and so so there's this idea
then that uh it's almost like a like an
idea of like the council of the gods
right
but it's it's the idea that we're able
to sort of like uh we have a sacred
place we have a sacred building toward
which
towards which the the states are able to
orient themselves
right and so like they're sort of joined
in the person of lincoln and one of the
interesting things that's happened is
that as we start to fracture again as a
society
you have people uh originally was the
right who
who like maybe 10 or 15 years ago got
really down on lincoln because they felt
like he'd
obliterated the whole idea of like
states rights or whatever but now it's
the left and they're down
like lincoln is sort of getting canceled
right so it's like lincoln was
like the one thing everyone could agree
on it that was the principality if you
will
that was sort of holding this idea of
the american vision the american dream
together
and as we began to fragment we're losing
our trust in that particular
principality yeah so i i
apologize we you we didn't mean to talk
about this but
uh was the fourth of july not very yeah
it was the fourth of july you're allowed
been on my mind a lot um right so let's
get back to this
yeah yeah so this marriage right so the
idea is that
the way that you the way that you
join opposites
right the way that you join two opposite
things which which again
i can't stress enough this is what the
whole schism is about
right and what the writer of this is
saying is that the way that you join two
opposite things
byzantium and ethiopia east and west
north and south the way that you learn
two opposite things
is in a person right so you join them
in the person of you know
uh this this princess that he sends off
to rome she has
three children one of whom is named
claudius
um and claudius rules in alexandria
and then eventually like the line of the
the romans
comes comes from him but at the end of
all of this it says this therefore the
seed of joseph
the daughter of full the king of
ethiopia gained
mastery over the macedonians and the
romans
so remember that the ethiopian is the
you know the image of like the queen of
sheba or moses's first wife
right it's this idea that the ethiopian
is the one who
is captured and then in her turn
captures right so she
she somehow gains mastery of the romans
because over the
sorry over the macedonians because her
son is alexander who conquers everything
right she gains mastery over the people
of the romans
by you know by this idea that east and
west the rulers the principalities on
both side
are now coming from her uh from her womb
right and so um and i think this is a
kind of image this is a way of
understanding
this is this is a way of understanding
mastery that i don't think is possible
in a pre-christian world right because
pre-christian
uh it's not biology but but like
pre-christian biology
is concerned with the seed of the man
the idea is the woman is basically just
like a container
she's basically just like you know
potential but she doesn't
contribute anything to that process and
then
christianity comes along and we get the
virgin mary right and the virgin mary
right you know because christ is without
is without a biological father this
opens up a space to sort of think about
women
as actually participating in the
birthing process
but not just that that the idea that
embodiment
is part of the story right yes
the power of embodiment is there in the
story of christ but then in the story of
the church
and the whole way in which let's say the
light manifests itself into the world
one of the revelations that
appears in the christian story is the
manner in which the feminine principle
plays a role in in revealing the body as
it kind of comes down
the cosmic mountain you'd say it's like
filling up the mountain with the sea
but there's a sense in which there
there's a participation there's a
there's this call back and
call back and forth between the
masculine and the feminine in the
in the kind of song of songs manner in
which so in which the world
reveals itself and this is this is how
we can both talk about the virgin mary
as
as being sort of like the secret
interior place
you know like uh the holy place right
but then also our champion leader
right this this is how we're able to
talk about her in a concrete way
right yeah um so so it says that the
seed of chuseth
and again women don't have seed so it's
the seed of the woman
you know which is which is a phrase that
goes all the way back to genesis right
uh the seed of chuseth the daughter of
full the king of ethiopia gained mastery
of the macedonians and the ethiopians
from the seed of the ethiopians this one
and it quotes quotes that prophecy from
the psalms this one shall stretch out
her hands unto god
at the last day according to the word of
the prophet
the blessed david looked ahead with the
eyes of the spirit
and foreknew that joseph the daughter of
foal
the king of ethiopia would begin to
rouse the kingdom of the romans
and he prophesied saying ethiopia shall
stretch out her hands
unto god
and uh so
and then it goes on to say since in fact
the great and venerable and honored wood
of the life-giving cross
has been set up by the kingdom
established from the seed of the
ethiopian lady this is talking about
rome now
which wood is fixed in the midst of the
earth which is jerusalem
uh which is why perhaps as is fitting
the ancient father david himself made
the statement thus saying
ethiopia shall stretch out her hands
unto gods the idea of stretching out
your hands
is compared to the shape of the cross
right
for there is no nation or kingdom under
heaven which is able to prevail and
overcome the kingdom of the christians
for as we have already said above
because the life given cross has been
fixed and made firm in the midst of the
earth
uh and it just goes on to talk about you
know the result of this is that the ends
of the earth are then
uh described according to be fixed uh
according to breadth and length and
height and depth so the idea is that the
cross becomes the measure of the world
right yes
this is this is why it's ethiopia too
because it's as if
it's the filling up it's the idea that
there's a there's a notion in which
there's a joining between the center and
the periphery
and that this this joining is what
christianity is and it's actually
the cross is already what that is and so
the idea of of
opening or putting your hands to the
ends of the world like
spanning the spanning the horizontal
right spanning the entire breadth
of reality you can imagine that as being
like the width of the mountain itself
is this the breadth of the of the cross
is the width is the width of the
mountain
and so this is the idea of how the
relationship between
um the ma let's say the emperor you know
the the king
and the ethiopian queen how this is an
image of christianity itself because it
it spans everything and already solomon
and the queen of shiva is already that
image that his
his wisdom kind of covers everything and
so this is where i think that in the
story of ethiopia as it's
played out here in the byzantine
apocalypse tradition
you see the symbolism of ethiopia sort
of the rectification
of the story of kane right
um that's why that's why i'm sure there
are people who are going to watch this
video and be like okay he's just talking
about
like kane and you know giants and like
what where's this going what does this
have to do with ethiopia
you know but but there's a reason that
every time someone tells a story in the
ancient world every single time
they start with genesis and they start
with abel they start with seth and kane
in the table of nations and nobody tells
the story of ethiopia
without starting there right because
because it's something to do i mean you
were talking about like let's say
multi uh different different kinds of
multiplicity and like uh confusion
versus synthesis right
which is really like babel versus
pentecost yeah exactly and pentecost is
really is this image
of the rectification of going down the
mountain that is
it's like you can imagine cane you know
and the curse in general going down the
mountain
and that the surprise of that phenomena
is pentecost because it's like you don't
expect it but then something happens
where the the the christ going down into
death
manifest itself cosmically as the ends
of the earth being filled with the
spirit of god right the land of ethiopia
is stretching out its hand
all flesh being covered by the spirit
you see these images and uh
we were hearing these images at
pentecost as well
another one at pentecost that that we
read is you know this passage from
isaiah says the knowledge of god will
cover the earth as the waters cover the
sea
which is a really symbolically
interesting
uh phrase because of course like the sea
has all these resonances of chaos
and death and division and multiplicity
and all these different things
and then so the idea is that that uh you
know the c is sort of the thing that's
without bounds
right uh you know and whenever god wants
to assert him
you know like assert his power he says
i'm the one that set the line that said
to the sea you will not cross right so
then for the knowledge of
god to to cover the earth in that way
it's like
it's like the knowledge of god now is
the thing without bounds the knowledge
of god is now
the thing that's like all-encompassing
right yeah there's an image that i love
to bring about which i think is one of
the most beautiful images that
saint ephrem in his hymns on paradise
comes about is he talks about how the
saints he talks about the rivers of
paradise going down
into the world he talks about them
becoming mitigated as they get further
and further
right from the center right they become
more confused more mitigated more
polluted you could say
whatever word you want to use then he
says the saints
the saints go down the mountain and then
they
come to the oh to the to the sea and
they walk on the waters
and so it's like that that's not a
problem it's actually if you're
looking in the right direction all of
that actually becomes glory
even the bitterness of the waters in the
end will will vanish and it'll become
something like glory
right so it's like there's no seed but
there's a crystal seed right
exactly that's that kind of thing yeah
um
so what follows at from this point in
the apocalypse
is this long description actually he
immediately goes into
a pretty long chapter after this talking
about now i just said that the kingdom
of the christians will never be overcome
but obviously the jews were the people
of god and they got conquered like
every other day in the bible you know so
like what's going on there like what do
i mean when i say that
and so he's he you get this really kind
of a long uh
explanation for you know why does god
allow suffering
why does god allow kingdoms that are
ostensibly christian kingdoms to be
conquered and overcome and things like
this
um and it's a it's a i mean it's a good
explanation there's nothing in it that i
think that
that would really surprise anyone uh but
his point is to sort of say
you know my kingdom is not of this world
but also sometimes it's of this world
right and there's like this i mean that
that's one of the big tensions right is
the
is that christianity uh is otherworldly
but also it has this very unique ability
to enculturate itself in all these
different cultures and kingdoms
not in a way that makes them essential
like byzantium can fall
rome can fall and christianity
not lose what it is right um and
in fact you know there's there's some
interesting some interesting
ways that that changed you know things
like uh some some of the prayers that we
used to direct towards the emperor we
direct towards our bishop now but some
of them we also direct towards the
people
you know that that line in the liturgy
where we say oh god save the pious
and hear us right that's that's directed
to the faithful now but originally
that that line was was said to the
emperor and that that was the point when
the emperor came into the church
and we agreed oh god save the pious and
hear him
right and so so there's there's there's
some really interesting things
that that kind of happen there so it's
like you know on the one hand
we can be uh we can be comfortable with
the process of acculturation
and we can also be comfortable with
where we came from right
uh on the other hand we
don't have to fear right because because
this kingdom or that kingdom falls
right so so he's so he's working through
all that stuff
and then he gets to the end and this is
kind of his view of the eschaton
and his view of the eschaton is that
uh there's going to be this this
invasion in the seventh millennium of
the world
uh there's going to be this invasion of
the sons of ishmael that are good it's
going to wipe out the roman empire
um and uh that this is gonna bring in
uh this is then gonna open up a space
for the invasion of these unclean
nations that alexander imprisoned long
ago
they're gonna flood across the world and
they're actually going to overrun the
servants of ishmael the sons of ishmael
right and then at the end of all of this
the last king of the romans
will manifest himself and this is where
ethiopia
comes back into the story so there's
this idea that the seed of
the roman people you know the seed of
the last king of the romans
has been somehow preserved during all of
this stuff this constant overrunning
over and over again and that the last
king of the romans is going to manifest
himself
and he will drive out these unclean
peoples that alexander imprisoned
so he's like coming from ethiopia just
like alexander did to kind of do the
same thing that alexander did
he's hidden in ethiopia like the seed
yeah in ethiopia
it's uh it's the the ethiopia shall
stretch out her hands unto god is the
is the um that's the prophecy that they
keep coming back to over and over again
like so so things are
said really bad it says honor is going
to be taken away from the priests
and the ministry of god will be ended
every sacrifice will cease from the
cease from the churches so we'll stop
offering the liturgy we'll stop off in
the eucharist
right which is which is actually tell a
lot of the mystics in our tradition have
said that's when the world ends that's
when
yeah when there's no longer someone to
serve the liturgy right
um you know uh maybe liturgy is saving
you you just don't know it i don't know
but um
you know but um uh it's just talking
about how bad things are
and it says a man will offer for sale
all this necessary equipment and his
iron tools and even his
burial sheets um which is a symbolic
image i'd like to return to
at some point in the future and that in
the middle of all of this
this is when the last king of the romans
will manifest and it says
trying to find the exact quote here so
this this
man will march out and proceed against
them
from the sea of ethiopia which is coming
from the direction of ethiopia
and send his sword and desolation into
yathrib which is their homeland
and will take capture of their wives and
their sons the sons of the land king
will descend upon those living in the
promised land the sword and cut them off
from the land this is the
the unclean peoples who have it says
from the sea of ethiopia from the sea of
ethiopia
yeah yeah yeah it's
it's almost like you know you haven't
been making this stuff up all along yeah
exactly i mean this is this is um
so yeah it says all of a sudden trouble
and affliction will come upon them that
is
that is the the people that alexander
imprisoned
and the king of the greeks that is of
the romans will spring upon them in
great anger
and will be aroused like a man from a
drunken sleep and this is that image
that that language that we find in the
psalms of like the lord rousing himself
from sleep rousing himself like a drunk
man right which is a weird way to talk
about god but it's in the bible so i
don't know what to
say you know and and this this idea that
you know that you know he's like
suddenly awakened to fierce wrath right
well that language here is applied to
the last king of the romans
and who men reckoned him at to be dead
and good for nothing
and this man will march out and proceed
against them from the sea of ethiopia so
it's like the last
of the romans has somehow been hid down
in ethiopia
while all the stuff has been going on
and everyone accounts him as dead as
good for nothing is lost that the roman
empire is gone the greeks are gone
the empire's destroyed all the stuff and
then in the last day there's gonna be
this awakening from sleep
and he's gonna proceed he's gonna march
out from the sea of ethiopia
and he's going to drive out the enemies
and he's going to yoke them
says with a yoke sevenfold of what their
yoke was on the earth
great distress will come upon them etc
etc
and all of this happens and there's a
brief
respite there's this brief period of
rest that comes to the earth there's a
piece
right before the eschaton and when the
eschaton comes
um this is when the antichrist
is unleashed upon the earth right and so
there's this brief
repose basically the idea is the last
king of the romans
he'll revive things one last time and
then the antichrist will be revealed
and when the antichrist is revealed
uh he gets these guys that alexander
imprisoned and he leads them on like one
final slaughter across the earth
and when this happens it says when the
son of perdition shows himself the king
of the romans will go up to golgotha
right which is where at this particular
time this is where the true cross was
right um uh and we still have you know
we have churches there and what not
he'll go up to golgotha where the lord
of the holy cross was fixed at the place
in which the lord underwent death for
our sakes
and he will take the crown from his head
and he will place it
on the cross and then he will spread out
his hands to heaven
and deliver the kingdom of the
christians to god even the father
and at this point the cross will be
taken up into heaven along with the
king's
crown because the cross in which the
lord
our jesus christ our lord jesus christ
was hanged for the sake of the common
salvation of all
the cross itself will commence to appear
before him
and his coming as a refutation of the
treachery of the unbelievers
and the prophecy of david will be
fulfilled in which he says in the last
days
ethiopia shall stretch out her hands
unto god
because from the seed of the sons of
joseph the daughter of the fall the king
of ethiopia
these last in other words the last roman
emperor emperor will stretch out
their hands unto god so that the
the cross is taken up into heaven the
last king of the romans who is also the
last king of the ethiopians
surrenders his spirit he dies the
antichrist takes over
and then jesus comes back like that's
that's the that's the way the apocalypse
ends
okay there's so much
in this there's so much in this one
thing i want to point out is
again scholars think this might have
been originally written in syria
there's a syrian tradition i think you
find this in ethiopia as well
this idea that at the moment of the
crucifixion when christ's sight is
pierced
that's the moment that the veil opens
sean ephraim talks about this
but when the veil opens the holy place
is shown to be empty
and there's a syrian tradition
that says at that moment the shekinah if
it was it was present in the temple
which other churches would say
wasn't even present but there's a
tradition a syrian tradition that says
that that moment the shekinah glory the
presence of god in the temple
left the temple it left the holy place
and it took up residence in the cross
not just in the cross but in every cross
so then there's this idea of like the
cross being taken up into heaven
at this last moment as a as an act of
judgment it's like
god withdrawing his presence from
rightful
yeah so that just before the end let's
say yeah
yeah so this is i mean this is heavy
stuff
and there's a lot of really yeah
definitely and also the idea of the of
the crown
being taken up like let's say there it's
almost there's almost a sense of
something like
the ascent of enoch and the ascent of
elijah
i've talked about this before where
there seems to be a pattern even the
ascent of moses
there seems to be a pattern that before
a massive
change you know before the end of a
world there seems to be this
the best is taken up but it kind of
makes sense in this in
that that's also what kind of causes the
end of the world well that's the story
of melchizedek right
um is that you know this is in one of
the enochian books i think a second
enoch
um that's the story of melchizedek it's
right melchizedek is sort of like the
last priest
of yahweh and he's taken up into
paradise so that he'll be preserved from
the flood
exactly right but it's also it's almost
like to be preserved from the flood
but it's also like the cause of the
flood at the same time because
you're taking the seed out of the world
you're taking the meaning you're taking
the thing that joins things
that joins things together and therefore
then the world breaks down
because you've removed it's it's common
principle
or the you know the thing that makes it
less yeah and so the holy people like
when when we when we hear this idea that
like saints hold up the world through
prayer
you know it's something like that it's
like if the saints are actually
functioning as fulcrums
to to to preserve reality and so and if
the saints are taken up
then then the world just falls apart
actually
so it seems like that's what's going on
in the sort of enoch and the story um
the story of elijah but it also seems to
be something like that that's happening
here like you said
it's the shekinah leaving the temple but
if the shakina leaves the temple
that's actually the presence of god but
now it's not just the presence of god
but it's actually
let's say the fractally the human
authority itself
or the good human authority that which
is an image of the
the of the reign of god and the world is
also kind of all taken up
into heaven and the phrase here the
phrase here
it's over the phrase here that the the
last king of the romans
gives up his spirit it's the same phrase
that's used of christ on the cross
yeah so the spirit ascends and then
darkness
appears right you know the spirit of
spirit of crisis
ends and then darkness appears in the
world the same and the shekinah
goes up like you said that tradition of
the idea that when christ dies and
gives up his spirit the shekinah leaves
the temple
you know it's a it's a it's a beautiful
image to help us understand what is
going on and
what that means for reality in general
and how
to make in the story of the the
apocalypse of
pseudomethodist it makes sense that as
the
the presence of god and human kingship
in that presence leaves the world then
gog and magog
and the antichrist take over because
there's nothing left to hold it together
this is even
in the this is even in i mean this is in
the scriptures in the wisdom of solomon
there's this long passage about
why do good people die young sometimes
right and we actually i think we read
this in the church on like the eve a
vigil
on the eve of feasts of like certain
certain martyrs and monastic saints and
and things like this but the the the
explanation that's given
there in the scriptures is this idea
that
one of the reasons that that sometimes
good people die young
is that it's a mercy toward them and
it's a judgment to the world right
because the saints do uphold the world
it's
the only i mean as far as i'm concerned
the only reason that the world continues
to exist and be upheld right now is
because there are people on athos
and there they're people elsewhere in
the world holy people people we don't
know about
right and that they're the they're the
real hidden
cause they're the real hidden life of
the world and that
if that stops yeah
and you can understand it bottom up and
top down at the same time it's almost
like
right if the if the saint is taken up
then the world is destroyed but the
reason why the saint is being taken up
is because the world doesn't hold
together anymore it's like those two
things are kind of like happening at the
same time
this is people don't realize this but
this is what's going on in that dialogue
between
god and and abraham over whether or not
sodom is going to be yeah yeah exactly
that's not just like
abraham is like you know trying to
trying to bargain god down
right things like this like they're
having a conversation
in which god is actually showing the way
that cities
nations the entire cosmos is actually
upheld
right and it's by the righteous it's by
the prayers of the saints so even ten
righteous
right even the praise of ten people who
are really holy
really seeking after god would be enough
to preserve
the most wicked city that has ever
existed from judgment
and you almost have a sense in which the
the bet
the bet that moses uh the bet that
abraham seems to be making
in that story is that his intercession
will be enough to hold it together like
his asking of god to hold the world
together will be enough for it to hold
together and it seems that it wasn't
in that case right
yeah it was at least enough to remove
the remove
his family from the from but even then
like you have the best being taken out
so that judgment can
can come and fall upon the city and it's
you know it's it's maybe from our
standpoint like pretty sorry that lot is
the best but i mean
but i mean look at your own life not not
you specifically john
us in general like like look at our own
lives and all the things that are in our
hearts right you know
um so yeah i think this is
this is just a really powerful story and
i think that
i think that once you kind of go here
then there are a lot of things about
even the modern history of ethiopia that
make you start to wonder a little bit
right um certainly if nothing else you
could kind of take away from this
this this text in all probability is
written at a time
when uh
this christian uh the the author of this
text
has seen uh the the fracturing of the
church
in the roman empire and the breaking off
of the non-calcedonian churches
followed almost immediately by the rise
of the islam
and the arab conquests yeah so you're
seeing these things happen
and he's trying to make sense of them
and what i think that he's managed to do
is actually to
intuit and to understand a very
important
symbolic pattern about how the world
works
yeah and what the symbolism of these
different peoples and countries is
to the point that i think he's able to
intuit
uh some role that i do believe
it seems ethiopia might have to play but
it's not just intuit there is a there's
a relationship between
intuition and causality in the sense
that right the the writer of this text
would probably also have known that
after chalcedon
that's when the nine saints went to
ethiopia
from syria probably or from egypt you
know from egypt or syria from one of
those places
would i think it was for from egypt but
they they
they go to ethiopia and they see
ethiopia
as the place to now build monasteries
and to kind of
create this bastion to hold the
christian civilization at least in their
perception
right so you can understand that as the
as the let's say
with the advent of islam that that
memory or that
understanding all of that would have
would be part of the story
like he also knew that that these nine
saints went there
and probably brought a lot of the texts
that were preserved like there was
probably a lot of that was going on
you know with with the this kind of
renewal of
ethiopian monastic tradition um and so
it all it there's a relationship between
intuition and causality all of this
is all kind of happening at the same
time so what i really want to do
um if people will let us i mean like if
if you'll let me get away with
and if i mean i've been pretty all over
the place today but if people will let
us get away with another ethiopia video
um which i which i think they will i i'd
like to actually look at those nine
saints specifically look at their lives
yeah um but it'd be good to also look at
how ethiopian christianity functions the
relationship
because the ark is fractally present in
all the churches i i've had a lot of
people in the last two weeks so
there was a there was a there was a
consecration at our cathedral
um uh we have so we have a new bishop
which is great
um but but i got to see a lot of people
that normally i only know on the
internet
and i've had so many people come up to
me in the last like
two weeks with like so did you know that
they actually have like a little model
of the ark and every
ethiopian church you know like uh
yes yes i know we there's a limit of
things we can talk about
yeah so i i think that i think that now
that we've kind of like
i feel like all our previous videos were
just laying the groundwork to where we
could talk about this text
and now that we've done that i think
maybe looking at ethiopian christianity
a little deeper
for our next video would be yeah i think
it's a great idea
and and to talk a little bit about the
different traditions and and also the
the these kind of underground cities
this underground city has this microcosm
of
of jerusalem and you know this whole
idea of a kind of a microcosm and a
crossing of
of places because if you go to these
churches some of the things you see
are astounding like their crusader
crosses
carved into these buildings and there's
there's this you can see that so much
has happened in these places that they
really was seen as a
um all through the middle ages
this memory was was preserved and was
participated in the in the grand story
and so
definitely that i think that would be a
great thing to look at in our next
discussion
sounds good all right everybody so so
yeah
i know that but i know you can't get
enough of ethiopia so we will definitely
be talking about that
in our lat next discussion and so i'll
also be interviewing dean
arnold who has written a book on
ethiopia dean is an orthodox christian
that i met if that i met i think a few
times
uh and he's written a book about
ethiopia especially modern ethiopia
and how it connects to this universal
story but really focusing on the modern
history and how he sees ethiopia's role
let's say as the ark itself in the way
that we've talked about
uh and so because i know very little
about kind of modern ethiopian history
it'll be interesting to also dive into
that
with him so so there'll be more on
ethiopia coming your way
so so richard thanks again for your time
i really love these discussions
so we can just keep going because
they're they're a lot of fun i'm i'm
down
let's do it all right so thanks
everybody and uh don't forget to check
out all of what richard is doing in
terms of amateur
uh you know and the the books that he's
participated in we'll put all the links
again in the description
if you want to kind of follow his thread
because he's also been on a lot of
podcasts so maybe we can put a few
of those links below that you can follow
you were on on uh
on why are we talking about rabbits
recently as well really great
conversation actually i think
uh i think just one of the most
beautiful
conversations i've had recently it was
just really lovely and uh john is a
great host a very easy person to talk to
as you guys have a lot of insight
definitely has a lot of insight
so so we'll put links to that in the
description thanks everybody and we'll
talk to you very soon